- [Kim] Hi, this is Kim from Kahn Academy
and today I'm learning
about the 10th Amendment
to the Constitution, the last amendment
in the Bill of Rights.
The Bill of Rights was
added in order to calm
some of the fears held
by those who felt that
the new, stronger central
government under the Constitution
might infringe upon the
powers of the states
or on individual liberties.
The 10th amendment was
specifically designed
to allay those fears.
It reads, the powers not
delegated to the United States
by the Constitution, nor
prohibited by it to the States,
are reserved to the States
respectively, or to the people.
So what does this actually mean?
To learn more, I sought out
the help of some experts.
Randy Barnett is the
Carmack Waterhouse professor
of legal theory at the
Georgetown University Law Center
and director of the Georgetown
Center for the Constitution.
Robert Schapiro is the Asa
Griggs Candler professor of law
and dean of Emory Law School.
So, Professor Barnett, can
you tell us a little bit
just about what that means?
It's a little dense.
- [Prof. Barnett] During
the ratification debates
there was lots of opposition
to the Constitution.
In fact, the Constitution
only was ratified after
the proponents of the Constitution,
who called themselves Federalists,
promised that amendments would
be made to the Constitution.
Because it was the lack
of a Bill of Rights
and other changes that
caused people to oppose it.
And so they said they would
put a bill of rights on
afterwards and at that
point in these ratification
conventions, conventions
started proposing amendments
to Congress that accompanied
their ratification.
So they ratified it and
they said, but here are some
changes we want to see made.
And one of the changes that
several states asked for
was wording that was very
much like what became
the 10th amendment.
A reaffirmation of the fact
that the federal government
was going to be one of
limited and enumerated powers.
- [Prof. Schapiro] And the 10th amendment
is an expression of the idea
that while there are more
powers given to the central
government of the United States
it's still the case that the
only power that the central
government, the national
government, can exercise
are powers specifically given
to it by the Constitution.
So the 10th amendment is an
embodiment of the structural
principle that the only
powers that the national
government has are those
that are delegated to it
in the Constitution.
As opposed to the states
who have general powers
within their boundaries.
- [Kim] One of the things
that I think we see
in the Bill of Rights is
many examples of the framers
responding to particular historical evils
that they had witnessed in England
or in Europe, more generally.
So was there something in
particular they had in mind
they were trying to prevent
with the 10th amendment?
- [Prof. Schapiro] I
think the particular evil
they were concerned with was
the concern of a distant,
powerful, centralized government.
That had been the
government of King George.
They wanted to make sure
that wasn't the government
of President George Washington
and the 10th amendment
states that the national
government is not an all powerful
body with general authority
to do whatever it wants.
It's in line with the
structure of the Constitution
which says there are certain
powers given to the national
government, there certainly
are definite powers
given to them but only some powers.
And that idea of being
concerned of a distant, strong
government far away from the
people is really what underlies
the principle of the Constitution.
And that's what we see
in the 10th amendment,
specifying that the powers not delegated
to the United States by the Constitution
are reserved to the states.
- [Kim] So what would you say is important
about the 10th amendment?
- [Prof. Barnett] It reaffirms
that the basic structure
of the Constitution is one of
limited and enumerated powers.
How limited, of course,
is a matter of debate.
But the fact that they are
limited and that all other powers
are reserved to the states
respectively or to the people
is now a matter of Constitutional law,
it's a matter of the text.
The other thing that's
interesting about the 10th
amendment is that in Congress
they added the phrase,
or to the people at the end.
The states did not propose that language.
The states proposed the
wording of the 10th amendment
and it just would have
stopped where it said
are reserved to the states.
And so that made the ninth
amendment less a states' rights
provision than the states
had wanted and less
a states' rights provision
than people read it today.
So the people have rights.
In fact, nowhere in the
Constitution does it say
anyone except individuals
or persons have rights.
It doesn't say states have rights.
The 10th amendment is
about reserved powers
and those are the powers
that the people have
to govern themselves
as well as other powers
and what this shows is that
the people not only have rights
they also have powers.
Perhaps the most important
thing, however, is to note
that these two are separate provisions.
That the Supreme Court has
sometimes read the 10th
amendment, or the ninth
amendment, as meaning basically
the 10th amendment that the
people have reserved powers.
But we know they're different
because they are put
in there separately and
in fact Madison placed
a much higher premium on
the importance of the ninth
amendment as opposed to the 10th.
- [Prof. Schapiro] The 10th
amendment and the ninth
amendment really speak to the structure
of the Constitutional
system, what it means to have
a Constitution setting
up a national government,
The 10th amendment is really
a statement of the overall
structure of what we call Federalism.
Certain powers given to
the national government
and then powers reserved to the states.
The ninth amendment
speaks more to the rights
side of things, that is,
we have certain rights
which are set forth in the Bill of Rights.
The first amendment about
freedom of speech and religion,
the fourth amendment about
protection against unreasonable
searches and seizures,
and there was some concern
expressed in the late
1700s that if you specified
those rights, did that
somehow mean that the national
government could do
whatever else it wanted?
And so the ninth amendment
says, the enumeration
of certain rights shall
not be construed to deny
or disparage others
retained by the people.
So it's in line with the
idea that national government
has certain powers but they are limited
because other powers are
reserved to the states.
And the power of the
national government may also
be limited because there are rights
that are reserved to the people.
- [Kim] How do you think
the 10th amendment tells us
that the framers intended
the federal government
and the state governments
to relate to each other?
- [Prof. Schapiro] The
10th amendment really is
a little more about structure
than about specific content.
So I think the 10th
amendment embodies the idea
that we should think carefully
about what are the powers
given to the national
government, understanding that
whatever's given to the national
government may take powers
away from the states.
And so the 10th amendment is really a text
that embodies the overall
principle of Federalism
that is implicit throughout
the United States Constitution.
- [Prof. Barnett] In
fact, the 10th amendment
is in some respects kind of a
replay of the first sentence
of Article One that says
that Congress only has
the powers herein granted.
States have the powers,
by contrast, and the 10th
amendment affirms, the
states have the powers
that are not granted to
the federal government
but are granted to them
under state constitutions.
So just as the federal
government has the powers it has
under the US Constitution, state
governments have the powers
they have under state
constitutions and the people
reserve all other powers to themselves.
- [Kim] So how has the 10th amendment been
interpreted by the
Supreme Court over time?
I imagine there have been
some cases about this
as the federal government
has gotten more powerful.
- [Prof. Schapiro] Exactly,
so the 10th amendment,
which really is just about
the structure of government,
saying some power is given
to the national government
and there's a concern about the power
reserved to the states,
the understanding of that
has really evolved with the understanding
of the breadth, of the power
of the national government.
And what we've seen over
the course of history
in the United States is
that there's been a broader
understanding of the
power of the government
of the United States.
That expansion has really
come mainly in two forms.
One is with regard to the
government's power to regulate
interstate commerce and
the broad interpretation
of the national government's
power to regulate commerce.
We saw that particularly
in the context of the
great depression when there
was viewed to be tremendous
social dislocation,
tremendous economic problems
in the United States to the
point at which some feared
that the American
democracy might collapse.
And the national
government then was allowed
to exercise more authority
over the economy.
- [Prof. Barnett] The Supreme
Court, in the New Deal,
declared the 10th amendment as a truism,
meaning as long as you
find a power then you can't
have a 10th amendment
objection to that power.
That's right, as a logical
matter, except that
if you continue to expand
your interpretation
of those powers then you
are basically violating
the spirit, if not the
letter, of the 10th amendment.
And finally then, during
the Rehnquist Court,
until today the Supreme
Courts started using
the 10th amendment to enforce the spirit
of the Constitution which
preserved the existence
of states even when
Congress was claiming powers
that went far beyond
those that were originally
mentioned in the Constitution's text.
- [Prof. Schapiro] So, in
some cases in the early
20th century you did see the
United States Supreme Court
interpreting the 10th amendment
to limit, to some extent,
what the national government
could do if, say, the issue
were child labor or minimum
wage laws, things like that.
A question is, is that really
something that the national
government can do?
But in the wake of, we say,
the New Deal legislation
that was put forward by
Congress in the great depression
of the 1930s and approved
by the Supreme Court,
we've seen the Supreme
Court take a much narrower
understanding of the 10th amendment.
Or, again, we can really
see the 10th amendment
in balance with the power
of the national government.
And as we've understood a
broader role for the national
government the role reserved
to the states has shrunk.
- [Kim] This is fascinating.
So one thing that interests me about this
in terms of US history
is the way that later on
the 14th amendment is
interpreted to incorporate
the Bill of Rights in to the states.
So how does the 14th
amendment's protection
of equal citizenship rights
then intersect with the idea
that states have certain
individual powers?
- [Prof. Schapiro] So certainly
in the wake of the Civil War
we saw the 13th, 14th,
and 15th amendments.
The 13th amendment banning slavery,
the 14th amendment guaranteeing rights
of national citizenship and
equal protection and due process
and the 15th amendment
guaranteeing the right to vote,
all of which expanded the power
of the national government
and particularly the 14th
amendment and its guarantee
of equal protection of laws
and due process of laws
were really new national
restrictions on state authority,
a new empowerment of the
national government to protect
individuals no matter
what state they were.
So since the structure
of the 10th amendment
is not about protecting a
particular body of power,
it would be natural that as
the 14th amendment expands
the role of the national
government that there'd be
less for the states to
do completely immune
from federal intrusion.
- [Prof. Barnett] The
14th amendment represents
a fundamental change to
our system of Federalism.
Precisely because it has
a section five in the 14th
amendment which empowers Congress
to enforce the provisions
of the previous four sections
including section one
which has the citizenship
clause and the privileges
or immunities clause and
the due process clause
and the equal protection clause.
So Congress is given an
enumerated power to protect
individuals from their own
state governments violating
their fundamental rights under
those section one provisions.
That's a change in our
Federalism that is consistent
with the 10th amendment
because it's a power
that is delegated to
Congress by the Constitution,
by section five of the 14th amendment.
What happened to that,
however, immediately after
it was enacted is the
Supreme Court decided,
and I think quite consciously
in their minds decided,
that this change in our
system of Federalism
was objectionable.
In fact it was the product
of radical republicans
in Congress and it really
needed to be undone.
And so in one of the earliest
examples of what I would call
living Constitutionalism,
in a series of cases
the Supreme Court cut back
on the powers of Congress
to protect individuals from
the rights of their citizens
in cases like the
Slaughterhouse cases or United
States versus Crookshank,
or Plessy versus Ferguson.
These are cases, the civil
rights cases are more
in which the Supreme
Court actually cut back
on the scope in order to
restore the Federalism
that existed prior to the Civil War
that the justices preferred.
- [Prof. Schapiro] I
think based on its text
and its interpretation
over time we see the 10th
amendment really being a
recognition of the Federalist
structure of the United
States Constitution,
meaning there will be
a national government
and there will be states.
And that has not changed over time.
What has changed over time
is an understanding about
the scope of the role of
the national government.
How much power the
national government needs
either to regulate the national economy
or to protect individual rights.
Certainly the interpretation
of the interstate
commerce clause and the
enactment of the 14th amendment
have been key elements
in expanding the role
of national power.
- [Prof. Barnett] But
all of this expansion
of national power is completely
consistent with the language
of the 10th amendment which
again does not specify
any particular kind of power
reserved to the states.
It just recognizes that
there will be a national
government and there will be states.
- [Kim] So how have the
courts been utilizing
the 10th amendment in recent years?
- [Prof. Barnett] In
recent years the courts
have been using the 10th
amendment not so much
for what it says but for its spirit.
The idea that it reaffirms
the importance of states
in our Constitutional structure.
What's happened since the
New Deal is the powers
of Congress under its
enumerated powers have been
so broadly or expansively interpreted
that if they were all
to be applied to states
they way they are applied
to private individuals
and private companies essentially
Congress could basically
run all the states using
it's commerce power
combined with its
necessary and proper clause
power, et cetera.
What the Supreme Court
has done in recent years
is said this violates the first principles
of our Constitutional
order which says states
are important, the 10th
amendment affirms that.
And therefore they've
created certain carve out
or special protections for
states from these broadly
or expansively read Congressional powers.
None of this is really
stemming from the original
meaning of the 10th amendment
because what's already
happened is the original
meaning of the enumerated powers
has already been exceeded.
But what it's attempting
to do is to keep in place
the balance between
federal and state powers
that the 10th amendment represented.
But doing so in a way
that's basically modern.
It's adding the states to a
list of protected entities,
protected from expansive federal power.
- [Kim] So we've learned
that the 10th amendment
reaffirms that the federal
government of the United States
will be a limited government
with enumerated powers.
But as the scope of the
federal government has grown
so has debate over the interpretation
of the 10th amendment.
Which actions of the states
can the federal government
regulate and which exceed federal power?
To learn more about the
10th amendment visit
the National Constitution
Center's interactive
Constitution and Khan Academy's resources
on US government and politics.